this morning uber is announcing a major
policy change on how it handles sexual
assault and harassment cases the
ride-sharing giant will end the practice
of mandatory arbitration starting today
it had forced accusers to mediate their
claims in secret those who agree to
settlements will not be required to sign
confidentiality agreements
uber will also disclose data on sexual
assaults and other incidents last week
we spoke to the company's CEO Dara Cara
Shahi about its stance on
confidentiality we have no interest in
closing down persons freedom to to voice
their experience or voice their concerns
so I think one thing that you will
certainly see from us is that to the
extent you go to arbitration and you
want to talk about your experiences or
what happened we're absolutely fine
without Tony West is ubers chief legal
officer and was an associate attorney
general during the Obama administration
he's here for an interview you'll see
only on CBS this morning welcome thank
you so let's first talk about this
because people who study the issue of
sexual harassment certainly in the in
the workforce know about the issue of
arbitration non lawyers out there
explain what it does so basically
arbitration is a way to litigate or
mediate your claims resolve your claims
outside of a court process sometimes
it's much much cheaper than less
expensive than going to court but the
reality is is that it's not the right
forum for all types of claims and when
it comes to sexual assaults sexual
harassment one of the things we learned
is it's very important to make sure that
survivors have control an agency and we
want to be able to give them the choice
of forum women have claimed that
arbitration in their work force have
helped kept these reports of sexual
harassment private you just did a
settlement it's done nothing changes in
the company so what's we're doing to
change that so a couple of things first
we are not requiring individuals who
settle their claims with uber to sign
any kind of confidentiality agreement or
NDA non-disclosure agreement that would
prevent them from telling their stories
if they choose we think that ought to
that decision ought to reside with the
survivor we're also saying that when it
comes to choosing whether a survivor
wants to
mediate her claims or arbitrate or even
go to open court that choice should be
the survivors as well a lot of times
when the choice is given to go to open
court the company makes it pretty clear
it's going to cost it's gonna cost a lot
so how does that posture change in terms
of ubers baby well I think I you know we
always want to try to resolve these
these claims in a way that is best for
the survivor that really always has to
be our main perspective on sexual
assault and sexual harassment claims
because you're dealing with a situation
in which control and agency has been
stripped away from a person but but if
you can't do that then we want to make
sure that we try to litigate these as
fairly as possible and we think that the
change is what we've announced today
will allow that to happen what happens
Tony with what what's already going on
or that's already in litigation well so
I'll tell you where our announcement is
effective immediately and so if
individuals are in arbitration and
they'd rather pursue their individual
claims of sexual harassment sexual
assault in open court or mediation
they're free to do that well as recently
as last month there were 14 women right
accusing uber drivers of sexual assault
or harassment and they wrote to Ebert
board asking that their class-action
lawsuit be allowed in open court what's
changed on that well again you know this
this goes to individual claims of sexual
assault and sexual harassment it doesn't
go to all kinds of legal claims we still
are having I think an important
conversation about whether or not this
ought to be extended to different types
of legal claims today what we are
focused on however is the safety aspect
of this you know one of the things we
know is that if we can continually
enhance the safety of our platform
particularly for women and for survivors
it'll make you beret safer platform for
everyone our Cosmo darah
Cosmo Shahi right you said the CEO has
made it clear he has a new mantra a new
sheriff in town he says do the right
thing period that's right and he is
called the past culture deeply
unpleasant and very troubling how do you
go about changing a toxic culture that
some said from within you're new on the
job yourself you took this job knowing
that there were issues at the company so
how do you go about changing it and how
do you stand on how you feel about the
company now well I'll tell you listen I
am I am proud to be a member of
uber family and uber community and
cultural change is hard any kind of
change is hard but obviously cultural
change is also a hard it's a journey
we're in the middle of that journey
we're seeing great results as we're
moving forward to actually make sure
we're doing the right thing
putting transparency integrity and
accountability at the core of everything
we do today's announcement is part of
that many of the things that you will
continue to see throughout the year and
going into the future will represent
that know that mantra struck me Tony
that do the right thing period this is
all part of that that's right this is
all part of that all right Tony was
thank you for joining us it's good to be
with you thank you good to see you